[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
crazy people
happy thursday everyone or as cat likes
to call it honey the police are here
flush the eight ball
julie banderas is back which is
impressive
i don't know why yeah i don't know why
and she's been so busy
[Music]
i get it julie you got bills to pay but
you can ask that's the best my abs have
looked in years yes i loved that video
all right enough
angelie earhart is here scared
who did she piss off
don't worry ainsley this episode won't
air
i'm lying all right
so here's something fun donald trump is
officially more popular than joe biden
it's true
oh you don't have to clap he can't hear
you
according to the latest harvard harris
paul trump rose to 80 48
biden dropped to 46. how is biden even
at 46. in a normal world he'd be at 2
just ahead of losing your home in a
tornado
yeah there's a lot a lot of things more
popular than joe biden tinnitus
painful rectal itch
pamela harris
but i repeat myself it's true harris is
doing better than joe in nationwide
polling which is easy to explain she's
doing nothing
he's doing something and research shows
the less a liberal actually works the
more popular they are it's because when
they do work they destroy things they're
like a bull in a china shop
one that joe and hunter are probably
silent partners in
except they're more like rats in a
sinking ship
or maybe there are snakes in a grass or
perhaps they're
you have exceeded your metaphor limit
you have exceeded your metaphor limit
you have exceeded your metaphor limit
abort immediately abort immediately
it's a new system we're testing out i
think it works
which brings us to joe remember how
beloved he was when he was chained to a
radiator in a basement
watching reruns of matlock
drinking a juice box and waiting for the
transfusion
those were the days when joe only came
outside just once to predict six more
weeks of winter
but then he won and had to get to work
and since then it's been a groundhog day
of policy failures gaffes and
catastrophes so they loaded joe up with
prevagen and relief factor
and they they pointed him to the white
house
where after eight attempts he found the
entrance
[Laughter]
and got to work and boy was that a bad
idea have you checked america 2021 under
joe it's now a strangely hobbled chaotic
mess in short biden remade the country
in the image of himself it's true the
country's just two weeks away from
getting hair plugs
the decline reflects his own consistent
decline it's sad he's falling apart
faster than a whopper you're trying to
eat while driving
[Laughter]
yet he claims he has things under
control like he had afghanistan under
control like he had the pandemic under
control like he has his bladder under
control
no the only thing under control
is joe
controlled by whom
well let's talk about murder homicides
have risen 30 percent in 2020 the
biggest rise since national records
began in 1960. you know the same time
julie was born
we're witnessing we're witnessing the
biggest spike in 60 years it's like back
to the future except that delorean can't
afford the gas but that's not how the
media reports it nbc claims that crime
is actually falling faster than cnn's
ratings
how did they get to that idiotic place
have they been dining with don lemon
if you watch a certain
state tv and you listen to conservative
media you would think that you know
entire cities are just you know enrolled
in fights and fires and whatever we went
out had a great dinner in new york city
tonight
well you know what don enjoys any meal
without brian stelter under the table
begging for scraps
anyway they based this drop in crime on
a report by a left-wing think tank which
deceptively combined seven different
types of crime coming up with an overall
crime number which nbc embraced like an
unpaid intern at a hot tub party
shout out to matt lauer
because thefts are four times more
frequent than violent crimes the overall
number hides the rise of violent crime
in cities they're cutting violent crime
numbers with non-violent crime numbers
the way a coke dealer would cut his
product with powdered laxatives
what did that ruin a few dates back in
the 90s
in effect sorry the nbc's reporting is
like telling a mugging victim to cheer
up because mail fraud is slightly down
so why would they do that well the spike
in murder followed the unrest after
george floyd's killing unrest that was
cheered on by the media they chose not
to report on the riots the looting and
arson because it would taint the
narrative of a greater american
oppression in effect we deserve the
assaults but now the data implicates the
media and the dems who let their cities
descend into mayhem in a perfect world
jeff zucker would be sharing a cell with
nancy pelosi
i wonder what the angry black male
thinks
[Music]
what up gutfield
i know it looks like i'm
playing my video game in a pink room
with a pink couch with frilly things
above me but it's not
don't believe your
lying eyes
believe me when i tell you it's a
green room with uh camouflage and i'm
actually sitting on a cannon right now
so pay no attention to the facts in
front of you
and for my next trick
i'm going to piss down your back and
tell you it's rain
but that's really not that funny crime's
up because it's up
and crime's really up
because of this woke administration
that actually makes me angry
don't make me angry
you wouldn't like me if i was angry
then there's the border or what used to
be a border for months fox sounded this
alarm but it was ignored because you
know it's fox we're evil
it's the greatest self-inflicted
behavior i've seen since shelley long
decided to leave cheers
imagine someone you dislike telling you
something that could really help you
save your life and you reject it because
their politics don't align
[Music]
oh excuse me man you got a little
something on your
okay yeah nice try mr red hat all right
i know what you guys are all about
just trying to be helpful
[Music]
hey excuse me i'm just grabbing an
orange shirt oh uh you got a little
lipstick yeah well you have a lot of
hate in your heart you disgust me
please
[Music]
hey just dropping this up oh oh my god
you gotta come with me the literal grim
reaper is behind you look i don't know
how i can make myself more clear i do
not want to talk to you you are on the
wrong side of history you're about to be
on the wrong side of death come on i
don't want to talk to hitler i certainly
don't want to talk to you
he's going to kill you yeah well global
warming is going to kill us all if all
your little red hats have your way
[Laughter]
oh my dream comes true applauding cat's
death
by the way uh shout out to the grim
reaper for taking the time to help us
with that
here in the audience tonight
a big fan apparently
so fox offered months of disturbing
footage that everyone else everyone else
in the media ignored until they could
find one image they could distort into
something worse than slavery oh look a
white man on horseback it looks just
like that statue of teddy roosevelt we
just tore down
what the hell are we doing here
what we witness takes us back hundreds
of years
what we witnessed was worse than what we
witnessed in slavery oh really
apparently thousands of blacks suffering
in squalid conditions didn't matter to
mad max until she could pin it on a
white guy well she could have done that
before but that guy was her boss in the
white house
so right now the two most basic things
that government should get right law and
order and the border have been
sacrificed on the altar of progressivism
and we're all getting splattered with
the blood and that's what is controlling
joe and ideology he doesn't even
understand joe is now unpopular because
we can all see what many of us saw a
year ago like one of hunter's dates this
was just a trick
america was fooled into thinking he was
as middle of the road as a squashed
possum but in fact he was an empty
vessel like a newborn child's mind whose
parents could fill with good or evil
values and now we're paying the price
with a disintegrating border and a
disintegrating president but hey at
least he doesn't tweet
let's welcome tonight's guest
he's disappointed more liberals than the
u.s women's soccer team author and
political commentator the great douglas
murray
she's written two children's books so
she knows how to deal with tonight's
panel co-host of fox and friends
she thinks outside the box unless it's
boxed wine and she's only here to get
away from her kids fox news anchor julie
banderas
and finally those shoes look great with
her ankle monitor fox news contributor
cat tim
[Music]
so first of all douglas congratulations
you have moved to the united states of
america is that correct it is it is what
were you thinking
[Laughter]
um i feel like uh salmon i'm the one
going up river as everyone else is
complaining that they want to leave this
city and i think that's flat out wrong i
think this is a great city i think it's
a great country it's a great time to be
here and i'm not listening to the
naysayers there you go what do you think
of uh joe biden's performance so far
um
it's not been the best presidential uh
start
uh i suppose i would say that he'd be
must be feeling sad to see these
approval ratings going down but he'll
forget about it tomorrow
[Music]
he certainly will perhaps in an hour um
do you have is there a central flaw to
democrats or the left that you see that
underlines all of these disasters there
seems to be like a con at least from my
point of view a conflation or um
the conflation of law and order with
non-compassion so that allows them to
condemn any kind of order or process
well they can't hold on to ideas they
start off i mean they they sort of
vaguely have an idea you should have a
board or at least some of them do not
all of them they have an idea you should
have a border but then they see a
photograph from the border and they say
uh there's a man with something that
looks like a whip and then you go no
that's a horse rain and they go well in
that case we'll solve this by banning
horses at the border yes and it's not at
all clear to me that solves anything but
that's that's that's a familiar pattern
they just find something like that to
pick on and this time the horses got it
but it can't be anything blame the
horses ainsley that's what i always say
i mean i'm telling you buyer's remorse
is a real thing have you ever bought
anything that you regret buying yeah so
sure right talk to the surgeon in the er
[Laughter]
bought a house that has termites
whatever it is yes you buy buyers
remorse is setting in that's what's
happening look at independents they were
the ones who took them over the line
right right now if you look at the
ratings back in january it was 60
percent a little bit above 60 percent
who approved of joe biden now
independence in the summer it dropped in
into i believe the 50s 40s we talked
about it this morning i don't remember
the exact numbers this morning this this
morning on fox and friends oh yes that
delightful show yeah
thank you continue uh and then now
september in the 30s those are the
independents those are the ones who are
more open-minded and willing to what has
he done right look at afghanistan we
have 40 days in and we still have
americans behind in enemy lines look at
the border we showed the videos we've
been showing them all day long on fox
and friends we've all seen them it looks
like a tent city third world country
look at gas prices going up our taxes
are going up donald trump yes he might
send out these mean tweets i'm not a
proponent of that we try to all be as
nice as possible i don't like some of
the things that he says the name calling
and things but i would take him over joe
biden any day when you look at his
policies yeah look at afghanistan look
at the border look at gas prices look at
our taxes
the economy
it's a no-brainer yeah much like joe
was that fair julie was that mean
no i thought that was fair i guess i
mean i i think he has a brain it just
doesn't necessarily work on all
six cylinders how many cylinders are
there in an engine i'm not even
i don't know but uh he does take me back
to my high f's analysis which i've
shared with you in the past which is you
know it brings me back to my high school
days as a former high school flunky
right when i was barely passing i used
to call them high f's to my parents to
justify the report card
what i find really shocking about this
is that kamala harris is actually
scoring higher than president which also
brings me back to those kids that
skipped half the school year and got
better grades than me when i at least
showed up and failed she hasn't shown up
and she hasn't done a thing so i gotta
go back to high school yeah
believe me i've tried
not for the girls for an education
how dare you i'd just like to volunteer
the fact that i own a white van has
nothing to do with it
yeah what are your thoughts on this
particular issue
oh okay thank you for specifying
uh i the poll also said that just 30 of
americans agree with the us government
overall and only 30 but that seems high
to me
because what exactly do they approve of
the govern the government in general for
me
all that they've done is you know assign
me a number to be identified by
uh tell me that i can't do stuff and
take my money to spend it on things i
disagree with so i don't like any of
those things i'm confused why it's so
high who is happy and who is this
working for
i don't know me see neither do i
and we have a lot of friends yeah we do
we do i do
i do no i do no you don't have no i do
you i do
don't do not try to make me feel bad
because let's start by me let's not do
this here okay okay later
she has to bring this her husband told
me i'm her friend yeah yeah that's even
her worst one she's a failure
she's fun
where are we hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else